damn shoot him already why is the gate
opening did BOM do something to cause it
open while he was running towards it
obviously not pierce brosnan basically
monks for the camera so that we can tell
his obviously not pierce brosnan Asst
also is this the damn he just jumped off
seems kind of short for what we saw at
the beginning just in case you confused
it with the contra dam in switzerland
poop peeping and then bond landed face
first into a dirty ass bathroom stall
less than four minutes into the movie
and james bond has already allowed
himself to be snuck up on sean bean
isn't dying in this scene no late double
listen ready to save the world again
after you double o six these secret
agents need to remind each other of
their code numbers james ring them for
england now they have to remind each
other of their own names you'll have ten
seconds now you say that but then you
give him seventeen before you act
what are you a Sean Bean isn't dying in
this scene either Oh blows gasps sighs
how did they not already do that with
all the previous fired bullets then
seriously these gas tanks are just ready
to fall once the gate gives way amazing
that the Russians built their facility
in this manner and that bond somehow
knew that by shooting the bolts on the
gates this would happen why is the
Russian military leader yelling commands
to his soldiers in English I can't hit
anything anyway
will he unintentionally inspires the
military air base and Just Cause 2 also
pilot just happens to be leaving to give
Bond a convenient escape plane and a
reason for the Russians not to shoot at
him bond shoots this gun up in the air
in a magic bullet still blasts the
Russian JFK off his motorcycle fine
yeah better not shoot at him or anything
one of the Hans a highly trained British
spy could get away in this situation
Brendan this is a really cool stunt
bond had no other option the chemical
facility was going to blow there were
Russian dudes about to kill him but no
fucking way
the chances of you surviving this is
like winning the lottery and then going
to Vegas to win the World Series of
Poker Main Event and then putting a
quarter into a million dollar slot
machine and winning the jackpot and then
getting struck by lightning as this
plane Falls I'll just wait for something
to block by view so I could be extra
nervous about whether or not he survives
now that we see bond flying to safety
how did he get up this high in the first
place remember the path he took he
jumped off this and he lasered his way
further down then he got to the bathroom
more down went down these steps
he and Alek went down this shaft for
England then they go up once here which
the movie is apparently saying is
the equivalent of a hundred floors back
down these steps and finally down this
conveyor belt suddenly he's on top of a
mountain in this facility on top of it
makes a zero to negative sense where did
all the Russian dudes go see reflection
Tina Turner nepotism the nine years
later subtitle functions only to tell us
that Sean Bean isn't dead I'm not the
driver's seat in this scene cheating
well I was just sent here to evaluate
you sending cute psychologist dibond is
like buying him hookers for the weekend
assholes the shot clearly establishes
the car's need to go brief stretch of
highway before encountering the cyclists
but then in following shots the cars
continue to veer in turn wildly movie
sets up the bicycle people to be a major
obstacle but then merely turns it into a
domino joke baccarat zhenya said I gave
not on that tub damn I was hoping her
name would end in doggy style also
character named accidentally inspires
entire Austin Powers franchise mimes
zoom and enhance cliche I trust you stay
on top of things
wordplay is fun screenwriting is easy
when a girl this hot screws a dude like
this you know that dude is dead scene
contains some sort of laughs based
sexual thing no sin bond sees a former
Russian fighter pilot with mob ties
going toward the battleship with a new
stealth helicopter on it but decides to
snoop around on the yacht for some
reason which gives onatopp and her
partner enough time to steal the
helicopter sure he sees the dead body
but it wasn't like he was expecting to
see a dead body sure these gun shots on
a ship full of people definitely won't
be heard bond shoves the guard and
expects to get to the helicopter already
in the air without getting detained or
shot and I don't blame him he's bond but
the movie will decide he's not bond
enough to win this round dead right in
front of you and an open bed a large
dose battaglia then types three letters
and suddenly the word knockers appears
on the screen ah god I am invincible
general Arkady Gregorovitch a room of
head of space division Russian security
requires high-ranking personnel to state
their title in English monka Janssen is
super evil in this movie and still not
my girlfriend onatopp shoots the vent
expecting for someone to just still be
up here and assumes death occurs it's
clean I should to ventilate someone
that'd be hilarious if you actually
check to see if someone was dead we
interrupt this live action James Bond
movie to bring you a cartoon about a
satellite mi6 can find a missing
helicopter via satellite honestly I'm
not sure we need highly trained
operatives for if you're capable of like
this space-based weapons program called
Goldeneye roll credits remember she
survived this by hiding under a small
staircase in this room Italia Fuhrer
unless you know seriously
they made it so you have to say your
name to get out of the computer room
convenient satellite crash gives Natalia
an escape from the building right after
she thought it was hopeless the only
thing missing from this convenience is a
dog with a bright red nose you might
have confused this with st. Petersburg
Florida but it won't look like this for
decades I was aware only of the one vote
is Grushenka there was a girl also geez
horrible investigation tactics he wants
to resign out of the blue how do they
not know when he's probably behind the
attack q test-fires live ammunition in a
room full of people Jesus even the
Mythbusters take more safety precautions
than mi6 don't touch that it's my lunch
funny but didn't you come into the room
in a wheelchair with a missile firing
cast you just leave Subway sandwiches
around on work tables I mean excuse me
this is Great Britain
so tube sandwich or is it underground
sandwich bond hold up a dude at gunpoint
outside a fucking airport car that never
breaks down breaks down right after we
learn about how it never breaks down
movie accidentally inspires Yahoo
avatars wait now I'm coming in a church
with an accent showing up out of nowhere
and this isn't an x-men movie Kieran
Impala 4 o'clock this afternoon 200
pounds of c-4 explosives on weights
until they change locations to finish
this thought random faceless asshole
dude is random faceless and asshole 56
seconds of silence statue graveyard
walking Sean Bean continues to be alive
in the scene oh please James put it away
it's insulting to think I haven't
anticipated your every move
um okay so why wasn't anyone plugging
bond full of bullets or poison darts
just now did they know he wasn't gonna
shoot
I trusted you Alec movie wants us to
feel betrayed on behalf of bond because
this one dude we only found out about in
this movie and it was in it for like two
minutes stabbed him in the back it
wasn't God who gave me this
face it was you setting the time is for
three minutes instead of six you also
let yourself get pelted by hundreds of
gas cans without moving which is amazing
considering you weren't expecting it
seriously how did you get out of that
live Alec makes the classic villain
mistake of keeping the only guy who can
stop him alive for some reason he
couldn't just kill him normally and all
the Bond movies ever to use an overly
complicated attempted murder this might
be the dumbest of them all because the
bad guy was also a secret agent and
knows how many scrapes bond has survived
in his life fun with your pause button
the dummies in his shot are happy and
contented why the woman in the passenger
seat looks like she's ready to settle
down and have a family after they eject
from this helicopter villain goes to the
trouble to restrain bond and the girl in
this chopper and programmed the
self-destruct missiles but leaves the
ejection function intact does he want
bond to survive well he steals the die
hard too from die hard too much English
can't murder actually two shades and
James Bond dumbest criminals ever said
shot five trying to escape why you
didn't just go ahead and shoot him
before saying this it's really anyone's
guess at this point not only had Bond
been put in easily escapable situations
he's been taken captive twice and still
has his cute toys bond smashes through
what could only be the place where all
the tanks are but the dumbass general
decides yeah we don't need to find bond
he's probably long gone by now let's not
kill the only girl who can finger me as
the bad guy let's put her in a car and
definitely go out of our way to keep her
alive so bond gets the idea to jump on
this three four three tank which if you
recall he saw looking out the window in
this shot doesn't even appear to be in
the same place as it was just seconds
before but later bonds matches through
this wall which would require
maneuvering around all these other tanks
or smashing through them which it isn't
going to do bond is sitting in the front
outdoor tank driver's seat but somehow
survives all the concrete debris bond
likely kills and injures many innocent
people doing this is this guy drinking
right now I might go a long way in
explaining some of his dumb action so
far in this movie or it's just lazy
racism
I know it's dusty but these guys don't
really know their own town enough to
know that they're about to hit this wall
or at least to know not that just wants
it Lee speed through at dusk loud this
Jeep explodes because another Jeep drove
over it bond stole this tank from a
holding parking lot full of tanks but
only measly cars keep coming after him
if he could control it from the inside
of the tank and not expose himself to
bullets why the fuck was he ever sitting
in the exterior control seat
these cops
banging all inconvenience each other
perfectly without bond even having to
get involved tank easily keeps up with a
car in chase through large city odd
totally smashes this police car and this
Russians cops insides are probably all
over the windshield but because bond
doesn't kill innocent people he makes it
out okay
truck literally makes a product
placement for a tank to smash through
movie inadvertently inspires tragic
third hangover movie unnecessary orders
so on a Tom knew that bond and the girl
were gonna try and escape today but also
that the general would recapture the
girl and be led on a chase through the
city by bond and a tank to this exact
spot that has some seriously good
contingency planning
now the did he get up here bond is able
to silently pull a tank directly into
onit ops line of sight without being
discovered also how did he know to come
here the car he was Jason could have
gone anywhere he stopped to let these
cop cars crash into him he basically
took himself out of the chase discount
snowpiercer
plunges alive mainly because you're the
one that's stupid but also because the
general decided not to search for bond
after he landed in the obvious court of
tanks give me a fucking break
bond somehow sped this tank ahead of
where the train was going does a tank
run on nauss zoom and enhance cliche
again unkillable woman is unkillable
so everyone survived that train crash
it's like a train full of Bruce Willis's
so where we starts at James yeah why
didn't you just do all this back at the
first scene instead of faking your death
and all that villain she means nothing
to me
James is right they spent a short
helicopter ejection seat ride together
and that's about it
they haven't even fucked or kissed or
anything bonus is online bucking not be
spies because that's something you need
to be online for also handy computer on
a train allows programmer to
conveniently battle Boris from a remote
location
fucking spike him I might be able to
find out where they're going well like I
don't want to send the convenience of
random computer tech babble but I'm more
interested in sending the fact that she
somehow has an internet connection
inside of a tunnel under a mountain on a
derailed crash train car in this train
crash into a tank and derail how
fortunate for Alec that one of the non
derailed cars just happens to contain
his secret escape helicopter I said the
time is four six minutes
same six minutes you gave me why tell
him the fun time why not less time
why even tell him that there are bombs
at all why not just leave and let the
Train explode and be on your way just
had me
we've got three minutes this is like the
15th time Alec has let bond live instead
of just killing him password was clearly
five letters but Natalya keeps entering
four-letter passwords also chair might
have been the easiest password to guess
since the one-two-three-four code and
Spaceballs what I seeked on but I don't
take it with me sure like I said this
idiot woman thinks you don't take your
arse your butt or your bonds with you
wherever you go time tracing of the
phone line I simply do not understand
cliche whew I was beginning to think
this Bond movie was gonna skip the point
my whole life I dreamed about coming to
the cut of Mia Italia gets the
preposition wrong I'll push any of the
buttons on that car it's gonna go
prowling around in it this is the single
biggest reach for a pun I have ever seen
who the fuck says this I'm gonna go
bombing around in this car who says like
that no one that's who
Jesus Mike Myers is embarrassed for you
before we save the world let's have a
honeymoon on a beach paradise now what
keeps you alone bond wins over angry
girls logic with the power of his strong
boner time is still a factor and we've
got 80 miles to go
let's magic sheet well surely Alec has
already arrived at the satellite and is
ready to fire another EMP let's wait
were they really on their own timetable
and we're just gonna round putting the
fate of the world at risk back on sexy
Beach James Bond man plane crash that
means nothing means nothing bond thinks
this chick is capable of dying yeah sure
let's kick him to death is the satellite
in range six minutes
damn you've had like two days to settle
this up bond has been screwing that
pretty lady's brains out the whole time
what do you been doing I want to be
pretty soon yes because that humongous
electricity based piece of equipment
totally fits in that tiny Lake and still
works when soaking wet
okay so the satellite was under water
the whole time did you have a deep-sea
diver build this thing under the water
did you build it in a big hole in the
ground and add water later because I'm
beginning to think either method is
pretty impossible lake drain no one who
is a bad guy for a living notices these
two too sincere one bond walks out
stupidly somehow knowing these assholes
won't shoot and two these assholes don't
shoot James what an unpleasant surprise
unpleasant maybe but surprise no way
dude you intentionally left him alive
time after time after time and you know
the Brosnan era Bond movies didn't age
very well when I spent half this movie
waiting for Denise Richards to show up
in the end you're just a bank robber
nothing more than a common
see now the movie steals from the first
I heart if the filmmakers had seen die
hard with a vengeance before filming
this movie there would have been riddles
to get right in front of you and an open
very large doors this computer has an
encryption in progress warning welcome
to the bottom idea in Soviet Russia
party finds you okay I know the movie
wants me as an audience member to know
that this is the bomb pen but honestly I
am too upset about how obviously you
strong-armed that thing into his
possession I mean that bond gets
captured and its pockets are emptied
which didn't happen earlier in the movie
when he was captured but hid whatever
and then after a scuffle with a woman
this guy winds up at the bomb pen purely
by coincidence every bank of computers
got exploded except the one Boris needs
to break the codes climax on gigantic
satellite dish takes place inside tiny
room no James I was always better at
talking villain risks his life to go
after hero because movie cliche of all
the movies to kill Sean Bean this is the
only one that let gravity do the bulk of
the work Sean Bean isn't dying in this
scene either finally No alright
worthless Americans are worthless maybe
you'd like to finish debriefing each
other at Guantanamo you see kids there
was a time when having sex akwonton Omo
didn't have bad connotations maybe you'd
like to finish debriefing each other at
Guantanamo
get up seiga-san right here off of this
damn right here on Islam jump engineer
don't react boys shouldn't have said
that
no more questions don't ask any more
questions that's top secret that
I'm going to leave them alone and not
actually witnessed and dying I'm just
gonna assume it all went to plan what I
have a gun in my room you give me five
seconds I'll get it
I'll come back down here boom I'll blow
their brains out Scott you just don't
get it do you you don't okay Showtime
lose the puffy guys big you're a sex
machine Mitchell that Mitchell is one
fair tomorrow just talk about Mitchell
looks like Grendel I must protest this
is my investigation you are my teacher
watch it from what I'm hearing it is you
whose order 30 seconds it started the
trace they made the second leg you've
got the satellite in Tokyo these guys
are good they're cross Transcom you've
got about 20 seconds bishop
I know this is probably a little late to
be asking but are you married
am I married what kind of question is
that how can you ask me that don't you
know me at all